hi I'm Matt Welch for reason TV
President Barack Obama's 2015 State of
the Union address was a timely reminder
that there are a few professions in
these United States of America as
profoundly immune to basic learning
curves as those a politician speech
writer and bureaucrat there's a speech
that bragged about the booming economy
at a time when the labor force
participation rate is worse than it's
been since Jimmy Carter it was a speech
that talked about giving a fair shot for
everyone just three years after the
state of the union address by Barack
Obama talked about getting a fair shot
for everyone and it championed a series
of free programs and initiatives that
will magically create prosperity from
the middle out without any sense of
trade-off forever amen gay Obama's
economics are stuck in the 1970s without
the added spice of wide lapels and
airline deregulation he has dropped all
pretense of delivering on the promises
that he made in January of 2009 a net
spending cut reforming entitlements
closing Guantanamo Bay his act was so
tired that the climax of the speech
literally was that he remembers back in
2004 when he gave another speech and he
still believes in this speech the same
stuff that he said in that last speech
the good news is that everyone will have
forgotten this turd sandwich by the end
of the week the bad news is that he's
still the president this is still the
Congress and we're all still going to
have to listen to this same drivel next
year for reason TV I'm Matt Welch